bonsoir louis triaud merci avec nous en
direct sur arte france alors
l'arrestation de l'opposant sont co la
semaine dernière pour des accusations de
viol est ce qu'elle est finalement louis
là la principale raison de ce
soulèvement populaire où il y a un lien
avec sa cote de popularité
je pense que la sphère son combat de
tout ce que nous avons dit je pense que
c'est l'élément détonateur d'une colère
d'une décennie au macky sall faut jamais
oublier que pour le deuxième mandat
le scénario que nous vivons aujourd'hui
avait déjà été définis avec
l'arrestation de khalifa sall qui avait
été mis hors de course parce qu'il avait
une affaire judiciaire
que sont ils des parlementaires avaient
été levées et qui n'a pas plu compétir
pour la présidentielle nous ensemble à
peu près au même stade aujourd'hui même
si un troisième mandat ni juridiquement
pas possible
pour mathijsen on en est à un stade où
on prépare déjà la prochaine
présidentielle et donc ousman sonko j'ai
en quelque sorte à travers son affaire
symboliser le ras-le-bol que les
sénégalais ont la foi de sentir que leur
démarche est à aucune de sentir que la
vie politique est aujourd'hui presque
privatisé à un clan et cette
privatisation ofit au président en place
donc ce sont tous ces éléments-là ajouté
à la pauvreté de plus en plus galopante
et la crise qui font que la sphère son
côté plus un détonateur qu'une affaire a
en elle même normalement tout homme
politique n'est pas du sud la loi donc
s'il doit répondre du ces m il faut
qu'ils répondent devant la justice
mais quand la justice est
instrumentalisée pomme les gens semblent
le penser à dakar ça pose un problème et
on est face à ce problème
est-ce qu'on peut s'inquiéter d'une
tournure autoritaire de la part du
président macky sall
je pense que la tournure autoritaire il
l'a prise depuis déjà plusieurs années
on l'a vu quand il a commencé à noah
faire de la bonne gouvernance en
attaquant le fils karim wade qui l'a
mise en prison qu'il a jugée à travers
un tribunal spécial sur lequel il n'y a
pas de possibilité d'appel parts au
jugement rendu
on a vu également avec la liste recèle
il ya eu d'autres taxis pure et simple
et dans lequel on ne peut pas dire que
la justice était complètement
indépendante vis-à-vis du pouvoir
exécutif
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya une vraie des
rires de la part du président sénégalais
ou de l'exécutif sénégalais et qui n'est
pas bon c'est une pratique était
présentée depuis plusieurs années comme
une vitrine de la démocratie en afrique
francophone en afrique tout court alors
plusieurs enseignes françaises ont été
la cible de pillages dans les
manifestants accusent la france de
soutenir le président saleh ce que c'est
le cas c'est un mauvais procès qui est
fait à la france il ya des entreprises
sera fait sur place qui gagne les
marchés qui les gagnent dans des
conditions pas très orthodoxe mais je
pense que le patriotisme en faveur de
l'économie sénégalaise n'est pas un
patriotisme qui devrait être contre les
intérêts 107
il ya cette histoire du froid c'est ça
qui traîne depuis de nombreuses années
la france a dit qu'elle a arrêté
aujourd'hui avec le 2 le compte y est à
la hauteur public français qui permet
d'avoir des réserves pour les pays
africains plus il devait remplacer le
français saint malo qui tarde encore à
se réaliser
matérialiser sur le terrain en raison de
la crise sanitaire
les coûts devraient déjà être tribune la
crise unique à ce que nos calendriers a
pris du retard
quel que soit aujourd'hui les
revendications qui sont sur la place
instrumentaliser la violence politique
en direction de la france est de mon
point de vue la solution il ya de vrais
problèmes politiques
il ya un vrai problème de transparence
de gouvernance mais cela ne devrait pas
se résumer à riz n 10 français
c'est un autre problème on est surtout
pas se tue en outre riche aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup mieux que maillot nous
avoir apporté votre analyse en direct de
lomé au togo pour évoquer donc la
situation du sénégal merci à vous